only one country has ever bombed the
United States with nuclear weapons the
United States for everything Oppenheimer
gets right it ignores one tragic detail
about the Trinity test in Christopher
Nolan's Oppenheimer the Trinity test at
Los Alamos New Mexico is a Triumph it's
a moment of pure success unique in its
separation from death and human
suffering an isolated display of the
genius simultaneously praised and feared
by The film's Narrative for one scene
and one scene only the most dangerous
scientific discovery the world has ever
known supposedly has no victims however
that could not be further from
historical facts or tremble you know
when nothing included there is likely no
place in the world where one could
detonate a nuclear bomb and have it be
harmless it's true that the blast zone
at Los Alamos was clear but neither the
scientists in the film nor their
historical counterparts took into
account how wind patterns would carry
the biblical amounts of radiation from
their isolated scientific Haven into the
unsuspecting communities nearby the
self-described to LaRosa basing
Downwinders or Trinity down windows are
a community of New Mexico citizens that
despite neither consenting nor even
being informed of the atomic bomb
detonation near their homes have been
suffering the consequences of the
Trinity test for over 75 years as noted
in Oppenheimer Lowes Alamos has chosen
in part because of how remote of an area
it was why would we go to the middle of
nowhere
for who knows how long scientists were
confident that those outside the blast
radius would be safe from immediate harm
the fallouts however they were far less
certain about after detonating the
massive weapon nuclear fallout rained
down from the Blazing atmosphere over a
200 square mile area north east of the
test this was particularly harmful to
the predominantly Hispanic and
Indigenous communities in rural New
Mexico whose produce drinking water and
livestock were contaminated even after
the detonation those affected weren't
evacuated or even notified by the US
government or the atomic bomb beginning
a cycle of death struggle and
institutional abandonments that
continues to this day in the end these
people were betrayed by their government
the ultimate sin in a democracy though
the bomb ended America's war with Japan
in August 1945 the Trinity Downwinders
War had just begun in the years that
followed exposure to traveling radiation
and contaminated resources caused
disturbing health problems for New
Mexicans in the affected area elephant's
mortality in the states skyrocketed by
56 over a five-year period rare diseases
began to develop an otherwise healthy
young individuals and of course cancer
cases were abnormally prevalent
surviving such illnesses was only half
the battle inhabitants of rural
communities and to make long Journeys to
expensive doctors in order to get the
help they needed if they were able to do
so they still face difficulty finding
and maintaining employment as their
symptoms worsened for many in their
Tularosa Basin medical hardships were
dwarfed by Financial ones it became
common for Barons to be able to support
their children's college education given
the Trinity test role in their plight it
would be reasonable to assume the
government would step in to provide
assistance yet several decades later the
victims are still fighting to be heard
the only
country that ever bombed our citizens
with nuclear weapons was our own
government in 1990 the radiation
exposure compensation Acts or Rica was
passed to provide financial assistance
to those struggling from the effects of
radiation poisoning caused by
governmental nuclear testing in the
1950s unfortunately this act failed to
include the victims of the 1945 Trinity
test and attempts to rectify this have
been rejected by the US government for
decades the issue is especially dire at
this moment less than a year after the
release of Oppenheimer a Rica program
will expire and there will be no more
compensation for harm caused by nuclear
testing thankfully a group of activists
known as the tolerosa based in
Downwinders Consortium or tbdc scored a
victory in July 2023 when an official
map of this Trinity test Fallout was
finished and released to the public in
an interview with axios tbdc co-founder
Tina Cordova described Oppenheimer
saying the movie is nothing but an over
glorification of the science and the
Sciences again with no reflection on the
harm done to the people in New Mexico
the tests provide actually produced more
light and more heat than the Sun so you
can imagine what that experience was
like for them despite many attempts by
Cordova and other survivors to contact
the production in Hope of convincing
them to include some mention
acknowledging the sacrifice and
suffering of the people of New Mexico no
one from Oppenheimer reportedly
responded or reached out
[Music]
foreign